okay so today's video will be on the
topic of speciation so let's go ahead
and get started so first of all before
we talk about speciation we need to
clear what is a species well generally
you'll see a definition like this it's a
group of organisms that can interbreed
and produce fertile offspring so here's
a question can a human and a horse
produce a hybrid well I hope you know
the answer to that question is no or
different species but the reason we're
not able to produce a hybrid is because
the DNA of a human is just too different
from the DNA of a horse and so if
organisms can produce fertile offspring
then they we call them the same species
now here's a man and woman why can two
humans produce children yes we are
members of the same species but there's
a better answer to that it's because the
DNA of two humans is remarkably similar
to one another in fact it's estimated
that the DNA of every human on this
earth is about 99.9% identical because
of this reason a man and a woman can
produce children because they are
members of the same species and their
DNA is so similar to one another
so if organisms cannot produce fertile
offspring then then they are members of
different species you know can a human
produce a hybrid with any of these other
animals that you see a chimpanzee a
gorilla and in the Ranga time and the
answer is no because the chimpanzees DNA
is about 1.2 percent different from
humans the gorilla about 1.6 percent
different from humans and the orangutan
about 3.1 percent different so you can
see it doesn't take much of a difference
to prevent organisms from reproducing
just a fraction of a percent and members
of groups of animals or plants are no
longer able to reproduce
and so you know can it cat and a dog
produce a hybrid I hope you know the
answer to that is no they're different
species but again a better reason why
they cannot produce a hybrid is because
the DNA of a cat is just too different
from that of a dog well how about a
chimpanzee an orangutan can they produce
a hybrid and again the answer is no
there are different species but again
they're the DNA of a chimpanzee is just
too different from the DNA of an
orangutan well here's an interesting
example you might be familiar with you
know a horse and a donkey can actually
produce a hybrid called a mule our
donkeys and horses members of the same
species it would be reasonable to say
yes but actually they're not remember
the definition of the species it's not
just whether or not two individuals can
make a baby with one another but can the
offspring then reproduce itself with
other members and so what we notice
about mules is they're sterile they're
not able to reproduce the male mule a
female mule cannot reproduce with one
another and for this reason horses and
donkeys are members of different species
so here's another similar example to
what we just saw a liger is a hybrid of
a lion and a tiger
so our lions and tigers members of the
same species it'd be understandable he
said yes but they're not again the
definition of a species is not just that
they can produce an offspring but they
can produce fertile offspring and since
ligers are sterile they're not able to
make more baby liders a male like or a
female like or cannot breed with one
another so therefore lions and tigers
are different species because they can't
successfully create individuals that can
carry on down the generations
and so now that we understand what a
species is a group of organisms that can
produce fertile offspring we can talk
about speciation and this is the
evolution of a new species and
throughout this video we're going to
talk about several factors that lead to
speciation one of those factors being
natural selection so here we have some
squirrels and they happen to live in an
area where Eagles are preying on them
and so survival of the fittest in this
case the brown squirrels survived better
than the orange ones a second flat of
fact there is something called gene flow
you know gene flow could be kind of just
looked at as migration here we have a
river separating two populations of
squirrels but if one of the squirrels is
able to swim across the river and
encounter the population on the other
side and then breed well this new
squirrel has brought genes from one area
to the next and this is something called
gene flow and we'll talk more about this
in a little bit DNA mutations so you
know every time organisms reproduce and
cells multiply there is the potential
for error now what if the squirrel has a
random DNA mutation that resulted in
it's smaller than normal growth could
this actually this smaller size actually
be an advantage and the answer is yes
maybe because it's smaller than the
others it can hide better amongst the
rocks and avoid those Eagles that we saw
a moment ago if it's not as large
doesn't need as much food and so
therefore it's less likely to starve so
these are all hypotheticals but I hope
you see the point that not every DNA
mutation you know is a fatal error
another factor a big factor in
speciation is something called
reproductive isolation notice how these
two populations of squirrels are
isolated from one another by the river
this is gonna be a key factor in the
process of speciation and we'll go into
this in more detail in a little bit
and lastly something called genetic
drift you know survival of not
necessarily the fittest in this case
sometimes it's good luck or bad luck
depending on what side you're on let's
say a storm is - is happening and here
we have a lightning strike causes a fire
and as the fire is spreading of course
the squirrels are trying to flee but
they're just unable to did their
adaptations that they acquired from
natural selection allow them to survive
and look at the squirrels on the left of
the river did they survive because of
their adaptations from natural selection
no they survived because they were in
the right place at the right time so
we'll talk more about genetic drift in a
little bit
so let's review a little more about
natural selection you know this is the
process where organisms with favorable
traits are more likely to survive and
reproduce and if we use our peppered
moths as reference you know we talked
more about the peppered moths in in
previous sections you know right now the
light-colored peppered moths have a
survival advantage because they blend in
better to the trees that's why they're
more common right now in this situation
so the environment will select
individuals that are more fit in this
case the light-colored peppered moths
are more fit and the dark-colored
peppered moths and so over time the
majority of the population the majority
of the group will be that will be made
up of numbers with the advantage so the
majority of the peppered moths had the
light coloration to them the rare
minority were the dark colored peppered
moths
but that began to change if you recall
over the years the trees began to darken
and as the trees began the dark and
notice how the advantage is now shifting
to the darker mods because there's birds
in the area and those birds are gonna
continuously look for food and now the
light colored ones are really standing
out and as time goes by the white
colored mods are picked off and eaten
and over time the dark colored better
dark colored moths better survive and
reproduce and of course the the birds
are still hunting the dark mods are
still reproducing and so this is natural
selection those that have an advantage
in their environment are better likely
to survive and reproduce
okay so the next topic I want to discuss
our DNA mutations you know random
changes in our DNA here we have the red
arrow pointing out a mutation we have a
G for guanine bonded with the a for
adenine you know that's an error right
there
adenine is both a is supposed to bind
with TC is supposed to bond with G so
this little mistake this mutation can
actually cause some change and let's go
into this in more detail and so first of
all DNA mutations commonly happen
whenever DNA is replicated you know the
act called DNA replication well here's a
cell with a piece of DNA and it is
bonded to T's C's behind it - geez and
so notice how when DNA is replicated
I've highlighted in red some errors
sometimes this happens now normally
there are spell checker enzymes that
will fix these errors but what if
they're not fixed what if these
mutations are not repaired well the cell
will continue to divide in half by
mitosis let's say and and notice how we
have a normal cell on top and a mutated
cell on the bottom well the mutated cell
continues to multiply and you know let's
go over an example I'm you know what
might happen as a result of a DNA
mutation like this and so one of the key
factors in the process of speciation is
mutation because mutation changes up the
DNA in an organism and at the DNA in you
know one group of organisms is not
compatible with another group than they
are members of the same species so we
have to look at mutation as a way to
change up DNA and so well let's go for
some three go over there's three
possible results of a DNA mutation using
these these butterflies' here and so
sometimes a mutation has no effect the
fitness of the offspring is not affected
these are called silent mutations so for
instance let's say the father butterfly
passes on normal DNA and the female
passes on a mutation and but the
offspring has nothing noticeably wrong
with it and so even though the
offspring inherited a mutation it's it's
Fitness is unaffected this is what we
would call a silent mutation sometimes
mutations can be harmful and that they
reduce the fitness of an organism let's
say that the male passes on normal DNA
and through reproduction the female
passes on a mutation to the offspring
and because of the mutation let's
pretend that this butterfly has a
misshapen wing well this would be
harmful it to its fitness it's not gonna
be able to fly very well it's gonna be
an easier prey for you know birds and
lizards and other things that would want
to eat it another topic I want to go
into is gene flow the movement of genes
from one population to another here we
have two populations of squirrels
this world's on top mainly living and
reproducing with those on top the
squirrels on the bottom mainly living
and reproducing with those on the bottom
but see there's a gap in the little
mountainous terrain in the middle and
and every now and then you might have a
squirrel from the bottom population
migrate to the top and one from the top
population migrate to the bottom and
this is what we call gene flow even
though even though most of the squirrels
on top reproduce with others on top and
most of the squirrels on the bottom
reproduce with ones on the bottom if
there's a little bit of gene flow like
this between two populations well this
is what will keep the population similar
enough in their DNA that they can keep
breeding generation after generation
after generation and they would likely
stay one single species however watch
this if gene flow between the two
populations were to end let's say that
there was a rockslide and on earthquake
happens and a rockslide closes that
little gap but now the two populations
are cut off from one another now there's
still members of the same species at
this time but over the years we would
think that the stopping of gene flow is
a key factor in the evolution of a new
species what we would call speciation
if there's no DNA mixing between the top
squirrels and the bottom squirrels
eventually the DNA of the group on top
becomes different the DNA of the group
on the bottom becomes different and
let's go over how that happens right now
so let's talk about reproductive
isolation in that previous slide those
squirrels were reproductively isolated
and that is when members of a population
can no longer reproduce and so what
we're gonna talk about is how we think
that this is a key factor in speciation
now remember how will we know when a new
species has actually developed well the
answer is when members can no longer
produce fertile offspring we apply the
definition of what a species is so
here's our squirrels again we just saw
them a moment to go right now these
squirrels are what we call
geographically isolated it's one type of
reproductive isolation in this example
reproduction is put is prevented by a
geographic barrier and so the members of
group a can the members on top the
squirrels on top can only reproduce with
other squirrels in their environment the
squirrels on the bottom can only
reproduce with others in their
environment and over time now that
there's no gene flow because because
prior to the rock slide there was gene
flow between the two populations but now
each population the population on top is
subjected to different natural selection
pressures the population on the bottom
is subjected to different natural
selection pressures for instance on top
pretend that the main predators in this
environment are snakes but in the bottom
pretend the main predators in this
environment are Howells and so different
predators will pick up on different
weaknesses in the squirrels and let's
pretend in the bottom population the
climate is different let's say it's more
of a snowy environment and so now we can
see how natural selection will begin to
change the squirrels on top from the
squirrels on the bottom
over time perhaps the the browner ones
begin to survive better through the
process of natural selection well in the
bottom squirrels maybe the redder
looking squirrels begin to we produce
better and survive better and you know
in this environment this is the
advantage and as time passes since
there's no gene flow between the top and
the bottom
every time they reproduce with one
another there's gonna be changes in
their DNA because of mutations which we
talked about earlier because of crossing
over which is an act that happens in
meiosis where DNA gets reshuffled over
millions and millions of years these two
squirrel populations would likely
diverge and become different species the
squirrels on top having incompatible DNA
with the squirrels on the bottom and
this is one of the key factors that
leads to again the evolution of a new
species
you know in this world map right here we
brought up the lion and the tiger
earlier notice how lions and tigers are
geographically today I should say today
they are geographically isolated from
one another and so the longer lions and
tigers remain isolated from one another
the more different the DNA of each
species will become and we would predict
that you know as time passes eventually
lions and tigers probably will not be
able to produce a liger now again we
don't know you know if that's gonna be
in ten thousand years or a million years
or however long it's gonna be but the
longer lions and tigers are isolated
from one another then the more different
their DNA will become over the over the
years but what if what if this case
happened what if a mutation actually
provided a benefit to the offspring
let's say the male passes on normal DNA
and let's say the female passes on a
mutation so the offspring is inherited a
mutation and what if this happens what
if it caused a slight color change you
know this number one it could be harmful
and that may be the color heard it in
its environment but let's pretend that
in this particular environment this
coloration allows it to blend better and
so here we have an example where maybe
just maybe a mutation can actually
increase the fitness of the of this
particular insect this particular
butterfly and now it's able to reproduce
and pass this mutation on this is a way
where a mutation can be passed on and
other members of the population would
inherit this and over time more and more
and more individuals would inherit this
DNA and this little change right here
can spread and we'll touch on you know
how this leads to again a new species in
a little bit another type of
reproductive isolation is what we call
behavioral isolation let's look at the
frogs in this pond this is an example of
where reproduction is prevented because
maybe the members of this population
have a different mating
ritual their behavior is different and
so are these frogs live in the same pond
are they geographically isolated from
one another
no they encounter one another on a daily
basis but let's pretend when they are
reproducing these frogs right here have
a high-pitched croak to them their their
mating call as a higher pitch that the
other ones just don't respond to and
let's pretend the other ones have a
lower pitch croak or a mating call and
the ones with a high pitch don't respond
to them and so due to the mating calls
the two groups are really isolated from
one another they might as well live on
opposite ends of the world because
there's no gene flow between the
high-pitched croaking frogs and the low
pitch croak croaking frogs and so as
they reproduce with one another the high
pitch frogs reproducing with other
high-pitched frogs changes in DNA will
occur every time they reproduce every
time crossing over happens which is a
part of meiosis this will we combine the
DNA out of the individuals and same in
the other group of frogs the low-pitched
frogs changes in DNA will occur because
of crossing over and mutations every
time they reproduce with one another and
as time passes the DNA the group would
become so different that even if they
were to try to reproduce with one
another they probably wouldn't become
they wouldn't be successful and we would
say that they have evolved into two new
species you know here's kind of a fun
little example of organisms that have
you know unusual mating rituals if
you've ever seen the male peacock when
they are trying to obtain the attention
of the female peahen the peacock will
spread its tail feathers really wide
open and they're just colored gorgeously
and then they kind of do this this widow
feather dance where they're trying to
get the attention of the peahen in order
to reproduce and by the way peacocks and
peahens these aren't the only organism
that have meeting rituals if we think of
I have a little fun with this you know
mating rituals that human halves humans
have you know we flirt with one another
you know sometimes we are cosmetics by
both genders are worn to maybe enhance
certain features and let's not forget
you know gift offerings you know by both
genders as well gift offerings to the
object of our affection and you know
dancing is a form of meeting ritual in
that it you know it's thought to maybe
show virility perhaps and and then let's
not forget just the displays of oneself
that both genders are guilty of from
time to time you know all this is done
to to potentially attract a mate and so
humans we have our mating rituals as
well so let's move on to another type of
reproductive isolation the third
temporal isolation and this is
reproduction that is prevented by you
know reproducing at different times of
the year you know some animals have
mating seasons you know here we have the
same hillside just the hillside on top
is it and the hills on the bottom are
different times of the year and here we
have a population of skunks and so in
this area are skunks but they let's say
they reproduce ahead different times of
the year
for instance the skunk's on top well
reproduced in the spring and every time
they reproduce with others in the
springtime you know changes will happen
in their DNA because of crossing over
and because of mutations and the skunk's
in the bottom will reproduce in the
winter perhaps and every time they
reproduce with others in the winter
every time they reproduce that we
changes in DNA crossing over mutations
will mix up the DNA of the population so
there's no gene flow between the two
groups of skunks even though they live
in the same hill and hillside
environment there's just no gene flow
because they're just not reproducing
with one another so as time passes the
DNA of the skunk's that reproduce in the
spring becomes too different from the
skunk's that reproduce in the winter and
even if they were to try to reproduce
their DNA has become incompatible we
would say they are no longer members of
the same species so moving on to our
final topic genetic drift you know this
is where changes might happen in the
gene pool due to chance and not
necessarily due to natural selection you
know the gene pool picture you know 50
animals that live in a forest well the
gene pool would be all the genes that
those 50 animals possess and so changes
can occur sometimes as a result of
basically in luck and so genetic drift
is likely there is I should say is more
likely in smaller populations this is
not generally something that we see and
you know worldwide events but it's also
typically triggered by let's say
something like a natural disaster you
know here we have a forest fire or
perhaps a natural disaster such as you
know a hurricane or a mudslide can end
up you know causing a lot of damage and
killing a lot of life and perhaps
leading to something called genetic
drift are contributing to genetic drift
and maybe perhaps even tornadoes so
let's go over an example
of genetic drift so in this case pre
mudslide care we have some beetles or
some insects and and they're living in
this green Foresti environment or grassy
environment and notice because the
environment is green the insects that
have the green coloration on their
shells are better adapted that is
because of natural selection natural
selection right now is favoring the
green insects because they are better
able to hide and blend in but let's say
a mudslide were to happen look at who
survives post mudslide notice the
survivors had nothing to do with their
coloration of red versus green they were
in the right place at the right time
survival of maybe the luckiest not
necessarily the fittest and so this
would be an example of genetic drift
now when the survivors reproduce they're
the gene for red red shells is now more
likely to proliferate and spread
throughout that throughout the remainder
of the population and so genetic drift
is a way that can change up the DNA just
a little bit now when you add genetic
drift to natural selection to the
various types of of reproductive
isolation that we talked about these are
all key factors that we think that
contribute to the evolution of a new
species and so there you have it if
you're in my biology class pause the
video and bring me your answers before
school or after school one day I'd like
to check them for accuracy thanks for
watching